Bonjour!
Après un épisode pas très gai sur les revenants,
j'ai décidé de rester dans le domaine de
l'imaginaire médiéval, parce que je trouve
intéressant d'étudier comment pensaient
et ce que pensaient les contemporains de la
période qu'on étudie.
En plus on approche de la période de Noël,
et qui dit Noël dit goinfrerie, banquet,
et qui dit banquet dit...
-Canapé?
-Indigestion.
-Non... Aliénor tu devrais le savoir, en
plus, c'est ton époque.
-Ah, alors, euh, banquet... Du faisan?
-C'est aussi le titre de l'épisode.
-Ah. Le pays de Cocagne.
Le pays de Cocagne fait partie de l'imaginaire,
du folklore médiéval, au moins depuis le
XIIIe siècle.
Au milieu du XIIIe siècle apparaît la plus
ancienne version écrite du mythe de Cocagne,
mais il est probable que cette histoire ait
d'abord été transmis à l'oral.
D'ailleurs, plus qu'un mythe, la Cocagne peut
être vue comme une utopie puisqu'elle offre
un contre-modèle à la société médiévale.
D'autres historiens y voient un rêve compensatoire,
ou encore un monde à l'envers un peu plus
sympathique que celui de Stranger Things.
Comme je le disais plus tôt, le premier texte
conservé évoquant le pays de Cocagne est
écrit au milieu du XIIIe siècle en Picardie.
Il s'en passait, des choses, en Picardie,
à l'époque...
Le texte s'appelle le Fabliau de Cocagne,
et il s'agit d'un poème de 188 vers racontant
le voyage merveilleux de l'auteur vers ce
pays imaginaire.
Un fabliau, à cette époque, est un genre
littéraire qui apparaît vers le milieu du
XIIe siècle et traite parfois de thèmes
quotidiens, parfois de merveilleux, avec une
morale à la clé.
Dans ce fabliau, plusieurs thèmes importants
se dégagent, alors je vais laisser Aliénor
lire quelques extraits que nous pourrons ensuite
commenter.
Annonce Attention, le passage qui va suivre
risque de vous donner faim.
J'ai faim!
-Si on m'avait laissé lire...
-Oh t'inquiète pas, le prochain thème te
correspond tout à fait.
La première idée qu'on retrouve dans ce
pays de Cocagne est donc la nourriture, l'abondance,
la boustifaille. Évidemment, ce n'est pas
anodin: la faim est une grande préoccupation
au MA, à cause des pénuries alimentaires
voire des famines. Après l'an mil, on rencontre
encore des famines régionales récurrentes.
-J'ai faim.
-Oh, tiens!
-Aïe! Philippe...
-L'autre raison pour laquelle l'alimentation
est si importante au Moyen-Âge, c'est parce
qu'il y a quand même près de 70 jours de
jeûne par an dans le calendrier chrétien.
Ça creuse.
Du coup, en Cocagne, on ne fait pas qu'assouvir
sa faim. On ne se contente pas des deux repas
par jour de la société médiévale, et le
jeûne du Carême n'a lieu que tous les 20
ans. Le reste du temps, on mange, on mange,
on mange, abondance pour tous.
Les hollandais appellent d'ailleurs la Cocagne
«terre de la paresse et de la goinfrerie».
Et plusieurs choses sont intéressantes à
noter sur les aliments cité. Déjà, selon
les différentes versions du fabliau, on ne
parle pas des mêmes aliments. En France les
maisons sont faites en poissons et en viandes,
mais en Italie on en trouve en fromage avec
des rues en lasagnes, et en Allemagne elles
sont en fruits, fromages, champignons, légumes,
et bien sûr on trouve du vin, de la bière,
de l'hydromel et de l'eau-de-vie parce qu'on
parle de gens capables de boire leur poids
en bière à chaque oktoberfest.
Ensuite, on retrouve dans les aliments cités
surtout des produits consommés par la classe
supérieure. C'est là qu'on va faire un point
cuisine médiévale, donc j'insiste: prenez
un goûter.
Le pain est absent de la Cocagne, alors que
c'était juste la base de l'alimentation médiévale,
avec au moins un demi kilo consommé par jour
et par personne.
-Il est donc beaucoup trop commun pour figurer
en Cocagne.
-De même, les habitants de la Cocagne étaient
trèèèès loin des 5 fruits et légumes
par jour. Là encore, les nobles en consommaient
peu, alors pourquoi se forcer. En plus si
le récit de la Cocagne est originaire de
Picardie: il y avait plein de légumes là
bas, tellement qu'on en était écœurés,
alors est-ce qu'on en veut vraiment encore
dans notre paradis gustatif?
Non merci.
Pas de fromage non plus alors qu'à partir
du XIe siècle apparaissent de nombreux fromages
bien connus de nos contrées comme le roquefort,
le brie, le gruyère, le parmesan...
Il est de plus en plus populaire, mais surtout
associé aux fous, aux pauvres et considéré
comme peu sain par la médecine. A dégager.
On ne trouve pas non plus d'épices en Cocagne,
tout semble être naturellement bon sans besoin
de sauces ni d'aromates.
-Comme ma cuisine.
-Ah! Il est possible que, puisque beaucoup
d'épices avaient aussi des vertus médicinales,
elles soient absentes de la Cocagne parce
qu'on n'y tombe pas malade de toute manière.
-Bon, alors? Qu'est-ce qu'on mange?
-Là c'est si vous êtes végétariens que
ça va pas le faire: en Cocagne on mange
surtout de la viande, plein de viande. La
viande était très importante au MA, à tel
point que le mot viande était parfois synonyme
d'aliment. On trouve surtout du porc, la viande
la plus courante à l'époque parce qu'accessible
à tous, de la volaille avec des oies qui
se rôtissent toutes seules dans les rues,
et enfin deux gibiers, le cerf et les oiseaux
volants. Étrangement, toutes les viandes
citées sont assez populaires, contrairement
aux aliments précédents.
On mange aussi des poissons: à partir du
XIe siècle, la pisciculture devient très
importante.
-Il existe même une législation royale de
1289 visant à freiner la pêche pour permettre
la régénération des fleuves.
-En plus il y avait 146 jours maigres dans
le calendrier chrétien: des jours où la
consommation de viande était interdite. Du
coup, on y mangeait du poisson, frais si c'était
du poisson d'eau douce et salé ou fumé si
c'était du poisson de mer.
-Rapport à l'absence de frigo.
-Pour accompagner ces repas, on trouve surtout
des vins mais pas d'eau parce qu'à l'époque
seuls ceux qui n'avaient pas les moyens de
s'acheter du vin se rabattaient sur la bière,
le lait, ou au pire l'eau. Par contre, pas
de dessert.
-Quoi, mais j'ai rien fait!
-Au XIIIe siècle, on servait des desserts
sucrés à la fin des repas parce qu'on pensait
que ça facilitait la digestion. Comme en
Cocagne on n'est de toute façon jamais malade,
pas besoin de sucre!
-Ah. Chouette.
-La Cocagne est aussi une terre de fainéants,
de cyniques, d'oisifs.
-L'oisiveté est
la seule activité rémunérée en Cocagne,
qui d'ailleurs s'appelle en Allemand «pays
des paresseux et des fous». L'argent gît
au bord des chemins parce qu'il ne sert de
toute manière à rien. Les fabliaux reprennent
souvent ce thème de l'oisiveté et du repos,
parce que dans la société médiévale le
travail reste longtemps associé à la pénitence.
Travaillier, en ancien français, garde son
sens initial de souffrir jusqu'au XVIe siècle,
et on le retrouve encore dans l'italien travagliare
qui signifie tourmenter, torturer, alors que
le verbe travailler se dit lavorare.
-C'est pour ça qu'en Cocagne on fait la fête!
-Le temps n'évolue pas puisqu'il n'y a pas
de familles, pas de générations, pas de
rois, et pas de calendrier. Du coup, les fêtes
de Noël, de saint Jean-Baptiste et même
les vendanges perdent leur sens premier et
redeviennent liées aux anciennes fêtes païennes
et paysannes. Dans le cas des vendanges, pas
besoin de ramasser du raisin puisque le vin
coule à flots, mais les vendanges étaient
surtout l'occasion de bonnes fêtes campagnardes
qui marquaient la fin des travaux des champs.
Les fêtes de la Cocagne s'apparentent surtout
au Carnaval et à la fête des fous.
Par exemple, toujours en Picardie, les fêtes
des Fous pouvaient durer un mois et on y trouvait
7 ou 8 temps forts durant lesquels les rôles
étaient inversés: dans les villes qui
les pratiquaient malgré l'interdiction de
l’Église et du roi, les chants religieux
étaient remplacés par des chansons obscènes,
des enfants exerçaient les fonctions de commandement,
et les prêtres pouvaient lancer des boudins
sur la foule.
La Cocagne est aussi libre: tout le monde
y est libre de coucher avec tout le monde,
mais il n'y a pas de naissances, parce que
ça empêche de faire la fête et il n'y a
que des adultes là-bas. Au XVIe siècle,
certains récits imaginent un arbre d'où
tomberaient les êtres humains lorsqu'ils
seraient mûrs, avec des vêtements qui les
attendraient au sol.
Cette liberté sexuelle est un petit tacle
à l’Église qui inscrit à partir du XIIe
siècle le mariage parmi les sept sacrements.
A partir de là, on ne déconne plus. Le mariage
est défini comme une union hétérosexuelle,
monogame et indissoluble. Les relations sexuelles
ne sont plus permises que dans le cadre du
mariage, seulement la nuit, dans une seule
position, et seulement 1/3 à ¼ des jours
de l'année parce que le reste du temps, le
calendrier religieux l'interdit.
Enfin, la Cocagne est une terre d'éternelle
jeunesse grâce à sa fontaine
de jouvence..
La vieillesse était mal perçue dans la société
médiévale, surtout que l'espérance de vie
était déjà bien plus courte que de nos
jours à cause de la forte mortalité infantile.
C'est pourquoi on retrouve également dans
le fabliau le proverbe suivant: «Si les
barbus étaient des sages, boucs et chèvres
le seraient aussi.» *gif de la chèvre
con* Donc, inversement, la jeunesse est une
grande préoccupation.
-Par contre, pour l'aristocratie médiévale,
être jeune ne renvoyait pas forcément à
un âge mais plus au fait d'être célibataire
et sans enfants.
-Forever young pourrait donc être le cri
de ralliement des childfree.
Dans la plupart des versions de la Cocagne,
ses habitants ont éternellement trente ans,
ce qui par un formidable hasard est aussi
l'âge symbolique d'Adam et de Jésus. Dans
d'autres versions, ils ont dix ou vingt ans.
On connaît maintenant les principaux thèmes
abordés par le Fabliau de Cocagne, mais qui
l'a écrit précisément? On ne sait pas
trop. Juste qu'il écrivait en Picardie, au
milieu du XIIIe siècle, et qu'il était cultivé.
Dans son premier manuscrit, il explique avoir
écrit le récit de la Cocagne à partir d'un
texte antérieur, mais on ne sait pas s'il
fait référence à un texte plus ancien ou
s'il raconte simplement ça pour donner plus
de légitimité à son discours.
-Je vais écrire une histoire fantastique
originale!
-Ouh, tu prends des risques, non?
-Je vais écrire un remake!
-Ah mais oui, elle était bien cette histoire,
ta version sera forcément bonne aussi.
-Quoi qu'il en soit, il fait référence dans
son fabliau à des monnaies du XIIe siècle,
qui sont remplacées dans les versions suivantes:
les noms des monnaies et des tissus sont actualisés
selon les siècles et les pays.
L'auteur était donc peut-être un trouvère,
un musicien qui chantait des poésies, de
la cour d'Amiens ou de Coucy.
Ou alors, il pouvait aussi être un goliard.
Les goliards sont souvent des étudiants pauvres,
itinérants, le genre de personnes à aimer
festoyer et boire. Ils écrivaient des chansons
à boire et des poèmes satiriques qu'ils
déclamaient lors de fêtes de village. Leurs
écrits étaient le plus souvent en latin,
à l'inverse des fabliaux, mais on en trouve
aussi en français ou en allemand.
Donc, trouvère ou goliard: nul ne le sait.
On ne sait pas s'il s'adresse à un public
aristocratique, puisque les personnages de
son fabliau semblent être des aristocrates,
ou à des bourgeois des villes, ou même à
des paysans, même si ça semble moins probable.
Pour en savoir un peu plus sur le personnage,
on peut s'interroger sur ce qu'il décrit
vraiment dans le fabliau. Pourquoi a-t-il
écrit la Cocagne et que voulait-il parodier
ou critiquer à travers son œuvre?
Il existe des taaas d'hypothèses.
Déjà, dans son éloge de l'abondance, de
la liberté et du farniente
-Far niente: ne rien faire.
-Il critique pas mal l’Église et la société,
merci Captain Obvious. La société médiévale,
à partir du XIIe siècle, voit fleurir des
tas de réglementations, d'administrations...
La société est de plus encadrée, et met
en valeur le travail.
L’Église en fait de même en condamnant
le métier d'usurier, qui revient à gagner
sa vie en ne faisant rien. La Cocagne proteste
face à tout ça. Dans son éloge de l'abondance,
elle critique aussi l’Église qui place
la passion de manger parmi les péchés capitaux.
-Grossière erreur.
-Et comme en Cocagne on aime manger mais pas
travailler, pour bien faire tout ce qu'il
ne faut pas faire, on n'y trouve aucun outil
et les aliments se cuisinent tout seuls.
-En réalité, moi non plus je ne fais rien
et ne cuisine jamais, ça n'est pas compliqué.
-Parle pour toi.
-Ce thème d'une société libertaire contre
une Église un peu trop dure est aussi repris
dans le Combat de Carnaval et Carême, de
Rabelais, illustré en peinture par Brueghel.
Il est aussi possible que la Cocagne décrive
une «abbaye de jeunesse»: à cette
époque, il s'agissait de groupes de jeunes,
dans les villes, qui organisaient des festivités.
Si on reste dans l'hypothèse que la Cocagne
décrit une scène urbaine, une autre idée
évoque le lien avec les confréries et les
guildes de métier. A l'époque il s'agissait
de groupes sociaux de personnes qui exerçaient
le même métier, dans un même quartier.
Ils s'entraidaient par des levées de fonds,
et surtout prenaient des repas en commun,
organisaient des jeux, des fêtes... Ainsi
la Cocagne pourrait être une allégorie de
la cérémonie d'initiation dans une guilde
ou confrérie. Plus encore, elle pourrait
être une critique des guildes modernes qui
monopolisent de plus en plus la vente et la
production. Encore une fois, elle fait l'éloge
de la liberté là où la société médiévale
se complexifiait de plus en plus, et supprime
la séparation entre public et privé.
-En gros c'est une société anarchiste.
-Tout à fait, mais qui ne propose aucune
évolution puisque ses membres ne vieillissent
pas, et cette utopie n'est pas applicable
parce que les oies ne pourront jamais se promener
dans les rues en tournant et en rôtissant
toutes seules, et heureusement.
Puisque le personnage principal du fabliau
dit être arrivé en Cocagne pour y faire
pénitence, il est possible que le fabliau
soit la description d'un pèlerinage. Au hasard,
le pèlerinage le plus en vogue à l'époque
étant Jérusalem, il est possible que l'auteur
fasse référence à ce pèlerinage en particulier.
-Une croisade, comme vous l'appelez aujourd'hui.
-Ce serait donc le récit d'un jeune parti
en croisade, théorie qui est renforcée par
la présence de monnaies orientales en Cocagne,
qui découvrirait un pays et une culture totalement
inconnues, et qui en reviendrait tout chamboulé.
Du coup, la fontaine de Jouvence pourrait
être associée au Christ ou au Saint-Sépulcre.
-Et dans un registre beaucoup moins exotique,
le fabliau pourrait être une représentation
de l'Au-delà. Au passage, merci de m'avoir
transformée en squelette dans le précédent
épisode, j'apprécie le geste.
Le voyageur parviendrait dans l'au-delà par
hasard, par une sorte de voyage mystique appelé
visio à cette époque, mais serait incapable
de le retrouver une fois retourné dans le
monde réel.
-Moi aussi, je peux tenter une théorie?
-Vas-y, après tout c'est toi la plus contemporaine...
-C'est une taverne!
-Évidemment.
-Chut, toi. Dans les tavernes on boit, on
mange, et on se regroupe entre marginaux et
personnes qui ont fini leur journée. Des
gens oisifs, quoi! Il y a énormément de
tavernes dans le Nord de la France à cette
époque, et je le sais, je les ai toutes testées.
Par exemple il y en a 130 à Paris en 1292,
plus que des boucheries ou des boulangeries,
et 200 à Londres au XIVe siècle alors qu'il
n'y avait que 40 000 habitants.
Il y en a tellement qu'en 1256 Louis IX, après
en avoir interdit l'accès à ses hommes,
déclare que tous les sujets qui fréquentent
les tavernes sont infâmes et sont interdits
de témoigner devant la justice, mais bizarrement
cette loi n'est pas appliquée.
Dans les tavernes, on fait aussi des choses
sérieuses comme lire des œuvres de l'Antiquité
ou raconter des récits folkloriques, c'est
donc le lieu parfait pour mélanger toutes
ces influences et en faire le fabliau.
Justement, quelles sont les influences du
fabliau, et qu'a-t-il influencé ensuite?
L'imaginaire du pays de Cocagne n'est pas
apparu de nulle part, il emprunte à des mythes
de l'Orient ancien, du monde gréco-romain,
des juifs, des celtes, des scandinaves, musulmans,
chrétiens, et... C'est déjà pas mal.
Et là je ne vais citer que certaines des
influences possibles, parce qu'il y en a des
tas.
-Dans l'épopée de Gilgamesh, écrite vers
-2500, le personnage principal, Gilgamesh,
recherche la plante de la jeunesse et de l'immortalité.
On y trouve aussi la description d'un déluge
pendant lequel il pleut «en abondance essaims
d'oiseaux, bancs de poissons, profusion de
blé, etc.» Pas de la pluie du tout, donc.
-Toujours chez les mésopotamiens, la terre
de Dilmun serait une région riche en récoltes
et à l'abri des maladies et de la mort.
-Chez les grecs, Hésiode et Platon racontent
le mythe de l' «âge d'or», repris par
les romains ensuite. Une époque bénie où
on ne connaît pas la vieillesse, un éternel
printemps où coulent des ruisseaux de vin
sur l'île des Bienheureux: le bonheur.
-On retrouve aussi une fontaine de jouvence
chez les grecs, dans laquelle Héra se baignerait
tous les ans pour retrouver sa virginité.
-Chez les celtes, le chaudron d'abondance
et le panier de Gwyddno Garanhir pouvaient
nourrir la Terre entière. On y retrouve aussi
une fontaine de jouvence, la fontaine d'Avalon,
et le pays mythique du Tir na n-Og où tout
le monde reste jeune. Ça ne les a pas empêchés
de se faire envahir par nos trou...
-Chez les scandinaves, le Walhalla se rapproche
du mythe de la Cocagne puisqu'on y mange chaque
jour la viande du sanglier Saehrimnir qui
reste entier malgré tout. Les racines de
l'Yggdrasil, l'arbre-monde, auraient aussi
des propriétés de jouvence.
Bref: beaucoup de mythes ont pu inspirer
la Cocagne, et la Cocagne a aussi été reprise
un nombre incalculable de fois après l'écriture
du premier fabliau.
On la retrouve en français mais aussi en
anglais, allemand, gaélique, hollandais,
espagnol, italien, finnois, suédois, polonais
et russe.
En Angleterre, le poème anglais de la fin
du XIIIe siècle The land of cockaygne est
inspiré du fabliau en s'adaptant à son public:
dans le monastère de Cocagne, qui se situe
sur une île au large de l'Espagne, les moines
ont l'habitude de voler vers des religieuses
qui se baignent nues dans un fleuve jusqu'à
ce que l'abbé frappe les fesses d'une jeune
fille pour les ramener au sol. Le monastère
est aussi en aliments, et pour se rendre sur
cette île il fait rester dans des excréments
de porc pendant sept ans.
-En théorie, on risque pas trop d'y arriver
par hasard.
-A l'époque moderne, le récit de la Cocagne
évolue. Au lieu d'une joyeuse description
des mœurs urbaines au Moyen-Âge, il devient
une critique de la société qui émane plutôt
des paysans, cette fois. La Cocagne devient
une terre gouvernée par un roi bouffon, qui
s'appelle Panigon.
-Il s'appelle comment, alors?
-Juste Panigon. En plus la société se retrouve
à nouveau avec plusieurs disettes bien senties,
durant la guerre de Trente ans par exemple.
Pour beaucoup de contemporains de l'époque
moderne, on mangeait mieux avant, au Moyen-Âge,
donc s'imaginer une société d'abondance
fait du bien.
Un autre point qui montre que la Cocagne devient
rurale est l'apparition du «mât de Cocagne»:
un jeu organisé pendant les fêtes populaires
de mai, qui consistait à enduire un tronc
de graisse qu'il fallait escalader pour atteindre
les aliments placés à son sommet. Ce jeu
est encore parfois pratiqué au Brésil, où
le mythe de Cocagne est apporté par les portugais,
et dans le village de Saint-Félix-de-Lauragais
qui pratique encore une fête de Cocagne tous
les ans!
Pour finir, la Cocagne est une utopie très
différentes des autres utopies de l'époque
moderne.
-On va citer l'utopie de Thomas More, au XVIe,
celle de Tommaso Campanella et la Nouvelle
Atlantide de Francis Bacon, toutes les deux
au XVIIe.
-Dans ces trois utopies, c'est pas franchement
la même rigolade. Dans celle de Campanella,
les repas ont des menus définis, on y mange
en silence... Et dans la Nouvelle Atlantide
les repas ne durent pas plus d'1h30.
-Et pas question d'oisiveté dans ces utopies
là... Pour que la terre devienne fertile,
il faut travailler. Pfff.
-Ces sociétés sont aussi gérontocratiques,
c'est à dire, à l'inverse de la Cocagne,
gouvernées par des vieux.
-Parce que les vieux, c'est vachement myst...
-Non. Le mariage y est aussi une institution
très importante, sur l'île de Thomas More:
deux adultères, et c'est la peine de mort.
-La peine de Thomas?
-Dans l'Europe moderne la Cocagne est donc
mal vue. Ce n'est pas une vraie utopie puisqu'elle
n'a jamais été réalisable. Elle ne prône
pas un retour vers le passé mais plutôt
une évasion vers un monde à l'envers où
tout est possible, et on l'associe aux révoltes
populaires et paysannes. Même les humanistes
ne la trouvent donc pas très respectable,
et préfèrent s'intéresser au mythe de l'âge
d'or par exemple.
Dans le conte allemand d'Hansel et Grethel,
des frères Grimm, la maison en pain d'épice
inspirée des bâtiments de la Cocagne devient
un leurre pour attirer les enfants à la sorcière:
danger, donc.
La Cocagne inspire toutefois certains artistes
de l'époque moderne: Rabelais reprend ce
thème dans La bataille de Caresme et de Charnage,
qui décrit un petit village oisif, et dans
son abbaye de Thélème. Bosch la reprend
aussi dans le Jardin des Délices... A la
fin du XVIe siècle, la Cocagne est très
présente dans l'iconographie, principalement
hollandaise, italienne et allemande.
Bruegel l'ancien et Bruegel celui d'après
la peignent également, mais Bruegel en dresse
un portrait plutôt négatif puisque les personnages
ont l'air lourds et assoupis tellement ils
n'ont rien fait de leur journée à part manger.
Et je termine avec Arcimboldo, qui en matière
de représentation de l'abondance alimentaire
se pose là. Avec le tableau du cuisinier,
par exemple, ou de l'horticulteur, qui se
lisent dans les deux sens.
-Comme cette vidéo: si vous la repassez
à l'envers, vous verrez...
-Mais n'importe quoi, toi! Bref, je profite
de cette vidéo pour vous annoncer que j'ai
ouvert un compte chez Utip, et que je possède
aussi un Tipeee. Et vous verrez une autre
vidéo sur cette chaîne avant la fin
de l'année!